the Texas man who shot and killed a
gunman inside of his own church is now
telling his story Jack Wilson says he
needed just one shot to take down the
man who killed two of his fellow
churchgoers on Sunday Wilson was one of
several people inside the church who
drew a weapon and responded within just
a few seconds
Mireya Villarreal is outside the West
Freeway Church of Christ and West
settlement Texas near Fort Worth Maria
good morning to you it was quite
something to listen to mr. Wilson
recount what happened inside the church
absolutely David let me tell you Jack
Wilson who has a law enforcement
training told me he is thankful to God
that he had the right skills to take
down this gunman
you know the congregation right now they
are trying to focus and move past this
tragedy focusing solely on the two
parishioners they lost this man wanted
to pray here tonight outside the West
Freeway Church of Christ Monday night
the community gathered to honor two
parishioners gunned down inside this
sanctuary Richard white and Tony Wallace
I lost two great men friends man that I
consider putting above myself who did
the same for me service was interrupted
Sunday morning when a gunman got up from
up hue and approached Wallace at the
back of the church before pulling out a
gun and opening fire a live stream
captured the horror I took out some evil
that took out someone that was evil and
had evil intent Jack Wilson is being
hailed as a hero for taking down the
gunman I don't consider myself a hero at
all did what I was trying to do Wilson
is a firearms instructor and head of the
churches security team the 71 year old
confronted the shooter who just seconds
earlier pulled out a shotgun and killed
two men
the gunman was identified as Keith
cannon a 43 year old homeless man from
River Oaks Texas Wilson said he noticed
him immediately that's what really taken
yo time Dan was the fact that he was
wearing a wig and
you know fake beard and if the Balkan on
his head amble and the long coat
according to Oklahoma court records the
gunman had a history of mental health
issues and violence including aggravated
assault battery and arson in 2012 his
ex-wife was granted an emergency
protective order from him
the FBI is working with local and state
investigators to figure out what may
have motivated this attack my
understanding is they didn't necessarily
have a direct connection he had been
here I think several times and and they
always are I think my understands
they're very open to helping people that
are that are transient the president
tweeted out his condolences to the
victim's family while also praising the
parishioners that helped in the
situation and the Texas law that allows
him to carry a gun inside a church the
West Freeway Church of Christ has set up
funds for the families to help them with
funeral costs and meals as they try and
make it through this tragedy tarika
Moriah thank you very much
you